The final answer is 2 root 35 plus root 15, all divided by 5. Now if you got
this one correct, that's amazing. You've really mastered rationalizing
denominators. We start rationalizing this denominator by multiplying by the
conjugate divided by the conjugate. Here our conjugate is 2 root 7 plus 2 root
3. We distribute 5 root 5 to each of these terms to get 10 root 35 plus 5 root
15. For our denominator, we use the pattern of the difference of squares to do
A squared minus B squared. Next, we simplify our denominator. 2 root 7 squared
is 4 times 7, and root 3 squared is 3. Next, we multiply here to get 28. And we
really know 28 minus 3 equals 25. Now I notice that each of these terms has a
common factor of 5. I can factor a 5 from each of these, to be left with 5
times the quantity, 2 root 35 plus one root 15. And for our denominator of 25,
I'll split it up to factors of 5 times 5. These reduce to 1, leaving us with 2
root 35 plus root 15 in the numerator. And 1 times 5 or 5 in our denominator.
Great work if you found some of the steps or most of the steps to rationalize
this denominator.